so in terms of crisis of faith in terms
of your search for truth in terms of
some of the dark places you've gone in
your mind
uh what's the good answer to this
question
uh
so for camus with mythic sisyphus it was
the question of suicide
is
what's the purpose
like
what's the good answer to why keep going
especially when you're struggling
especially when you're not
um
when you're feeling hopeless
when you're feeling like a burden
in this search for truth
where you feel like you're surrounded by
lies
what's a good answer to where i live
i think you ever found one
well it says the simple answer right now
is to say for
it's very easy once you have kids to say
the right answer is you just of course
you brought these kids into the world
so you have a responsibility that i feel
deeply as a father to them
to always be there for as long as i
humanly can
and to take care of them and protect
them it's the most innate
sense in me i'm just you know it's that
it's wired in my animal
my animal existence
so if i take that away right because
that's kind of cheating let's put that
aside because it is cheating it's
cheating there's still you're still
there's still some fundamental way in
which you're alone
yeah
and to that
um
that that actually has been a real
struggle for me from for many years i
had a real turning point early in my
career
where we were flying
somewhere overseas
and
we were in a really small plane
and
the lights went out and like all these
red lights were flashing and the plane
just started to dive
completely like scariest plane
experience i've ever been in my manager
was next to me who's my brother
he was crying and texting his wife a
goodbye
that's how like crazy this moment was
was it real like genuine that's genuine
like this like genuine engine went out
plane is going down pilots
looking like crazy in the front and it
was a really tiny jet
and and like i said my brother next to
me crying typing a text to his wife
really really scary
and i
felt nothing i genuinely genuinely sat
there and i was like
this might actually be nice
like i i really felt like
this goes down and like
oh man life sucks it's hard and that
sounds so ridiculous i know to say
because i again i like i'm in a
different place now and i see my life
for what it is but at that moment i did
not
so life was primarily defined by
suffering it was a burden and it was it
was well lifted i was incredibly
depressed i had been on trying different
medications since i was young and i just
had not found anything that was working
for me and then i was in a faith crisis
lost all my faith
um started a band that
just became i wasn't ever thinking that
this band i was like when you call your
band imagine dragons you're not thinking
that it's gonna be big okay it was like
i was like
this was like a side project that was
fun for me it was like art in college i
was at in school and i was like man i
hate this biology class i'm gonna write
down band names like you know what i
mean like
it was not
hey put everything aside
this is my career let's go like it just
it happened and
i'm an introvert by nature it's i'm
really not an extroverted person who
likes to go out and like
i like to be at home with a couple
friends and have a late night
conversation over good food like that to
me is a perfect night read a good book
listen to a podcast go on a walk
um you know those are things that i
really really enjoy
and suddenly i'm in this life where i'm
like supposed to be something that i
really don't want to be
except for on stage which is a really
fast like strange thing to me which is
on stage i feel so free and exuberant
and like
an extrovert
and then i come off and i just feel like
shrivel back into a show like it's a
it's i i music does that for me and
performing on a stage does that for me
you